hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast modified dental composite
for bone repair I'm Christie jewel of
lab routes and I'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is brought to you by
labyrinth and sponsored by get Co by
thermo Fisher get Co cell culture heroes
is a program putting PhD and postdoc
researchers around the world in the
spotlight for more information on our
sponsor please visit thermo Fisher comm
forward slash cell culture heroes now
let's get started I would like to remind
everyone that today's event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send you can also see at
the top of the page multiple tabs please
click through our related applications
upcoming on-demand webinars as well as
links to the cell culture heroes web
page you may be our next so culture hero
also please notice you can share this
webinar on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event now if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
down at the top right of your
presentation window or use the ask a
question box to let us know you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I would
now like to introduce today's presenter
Maya Arshad PhD student at the
University of College lended for a
complete biography on Maya please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
welcome - thank you for joining us today
you may now begin your presentation
Thank You Christy for that introduction
so and today hello everyone I will be
talking about my PhD project which is on
modify dental composites for bone repair
so a quick outline of what I will be
discussing today I will be talking about
the osteoporotic treatment and how it
works what's out there will ready in
terms of what's already out there I will
be discussing the risks associated with
the treatment of osteoporotic fractures
and how I am addressing these problems
these risks and limitations with my
project
and then I will briefly go over some
future projects I'm interested in
so osteoporotic bone is the result of a
decrease in bone density we can see the
difference in the bones
microarchitecture between the healthy
bone and the osteoporotic bone in these
figures
osteoporotic bone has an increased risk
of fractures which often occur in the
spine these are referred to as
osteoporotic fractures
with age the risk of fractures increases
and this is due to the reduction of the
mineral density and as well as the
increase rates of fall among the elderly
and because there is a increase in the
elderly population better management of
this condition is required there's also
a huge burden on the medical system
especially in the UK on the NHS though
better management would benefit the
costs that go into treating these
patients as well
the current treatment or osteoporotic
fractures is ready bearer plasti and
kyphoplasty in kyphoplasty a thin
catheter tube with a balloon at the tip
is guided into the vertebra the balloon
is then inflated to create a cavity in
which liquid bone cement is injected the
balloon is then deflated and removed and
the bone cement has been injected into
the cavity vertebroplasty is a procedure
in which bone cement is directly
injected in the fractured vertebra and
the cement hardens within approximately
10 minutes appears the man Dental
Institute various dental composites are
prepared and for tooth fillings so my
PhD project is looking at using these
composites for bone repair
though the most current commercial
product is polymethylmethacrylate
I'll be referring to as PMMA during this
presentation and in the market there are
about 14 types of PMMA PMMA is the most
commonly used bone cement currently
however there's a list of problems that
are associated with this product
manually preparation is required prior
to surgery as the setting time is too
slow heat is generated during the
setting time so normally it comes in a
paste form and powder and liquid when it
makes it the paceful and then once it
starts to react its cuts are solidified
that's the aim of the product but
however German was processed a lot of
heat is generated and it's damaging to
the surrounding site of the fractured
sites also there's a mechanical mismatch
often it's too stiff in comparison to
the bone it's being treated on and as a
result because of the setting time and
then one of the material the components
of PMMA this can make the material very
toxic and again second time can lead to
leakage and a lot of clinical studies
have shown to patients to have bacterial
infections and with this product
there's no successful antibacterial
action another form of bone cement is
calcium phosphate cement
now these cements consist of calcium
phosphate to help be similar to help
them sort of be very similar to bone
because our bone consists of calcium and
also these and cements are porous and
the cells like wants to be poorest allow
integration
however this compromises on strength
also they have a shorter setting time
compared to PMMA that this then also
compromises on this strength and this
mechanical strength is not very strong
and again there's an unsuccessful
antibacterial action
aim is to develop a low modulus and high
conversion bone composite that provides
bioactive and osteoconductive properties
for synthetic applications we want a
quick setting bone cement upon injection
at the fracture site
and osteoconductive material will
present us for integration where there
is formation of a direct interface
between an implant and bro
digger a is a representation of a normal
joint we can see the in virtual disks
between the bones and the red circles
are representing the blood vessels theta
B is a failed fusion where a fibrous
capsule has been formed between the bone
and the implant this is a typical
situation often seen post-op between
polymethylmethacrylate PMMA and bone
after a vertebra plastic procedure
bigger C is the desired outcome we are
hoping to see using our composit where
the implant and bone have a direct
interface so the problems I'm addressing
on my page PhD are the preparation
technique setting time heat generation
and mechanical and chemical mismatch and
toxicity
so looking at the preparation technique
most commonly commercial polymethyl
methacrylate cements require a bit of
equipment you get a powder form which
then used to mix into a liquid form and
then is taken up using a syringe and
then apply to the patient using an
injectable range our composite doesn't
require any of these steps our composite
can be directly applied to the fractured
side each site using a double-barrel
syringe where the double-barrel syringe
consists of two separate components
they're pressed at the same time
pressure is applied and they're both
mixed via the automatic mixing tip and
our paste is ready to start the reaction
which I will discuss further in the
presentation
so the composite components why our
composite requires a double-barrel
syringe the double barrel syringes
requires because our composites are very
similar to to filling composite where
light is required to cure the paste into
a solid our composite and cannot be used
by a light cure one of the obvious
reasons it's because it's applied inside
the body and it will be difficult to
apply UV light within the fracture site
so we have an initiate an activator
phase once mixed that's what starts the
pace to set into a solid from the
initiator an activator both consist of
bulk monomers and their role is just to
act as a courier they also it has a high
molecular weight chemically so and due
to its structure it increases the
conversion time and it's less toxic than
other monomers are used another monomer
PPG DMA kima its acts as an addition
promoter very commonly used in dental
composites for allowing fillings to
attach to the tooth and again here the
idea is that bone is similar to tooth so
it will allow the composite to affirm
bone to bone also for meta so the
difference between the two
that go in the double-barrel syringe is
BP the initiator and MTG makes the
activator
also what's important about a composites
one of the components is that they
consist of monocalcium phosphate these
allow the mineralization which means the
composite was released components that
in chemistry are very similar to bone
and this will allow integration with
burn
we've also added poly live scene it's a
very common antibacterial agent in food
product and we're hoping that this will
work as opposed to anti bacterial
antibiotics because there's a lot of
resistance to antibiotics at the moment
rather than colonizing this is not
seriously
the first problem and second time we
want to see if we can influence the set
in time and we can do this by decreasing
or increasing the levels of BP and MTG
GMA
the ratio the same at five to three I
bought in this range 2cm how much of
this could be influenced by keeping the
ratio the same with increasing levels of
BP and decreasing levels of BP also
so once you initiate an activator mix
due to the free radical reaction they
start a chain reaction that joins the
single monomer comes to get by in long
linear polymer chain once these have
formed the second diamond cyclic
cross-linked the polymer chains into a
network the level off reaction can be
monitored using Fourier transform
infrared spectroscopy and the C bond o
Peaks shift during polymerization to
allo away from in virgi to its change in
its vibration frequency indicated in the
circle
so upon activating the polymerization of
a monolith acrylate such as PMMA there
is a rapid reaction and like the
animation just shown deformation of a
long polymer chain however often when
you use a mono methacrylate you have
some unreacted monomer monomers within
the chain which cause leakage which is a
problem with the commercial PMMA later
leading to toxicity these problems arise
in the commercial products however our
composite consists of dinah that relates
where after 50 percent monomer
conversion there is a second reaction
likely shown in the animation and that
their chains cross-linked so first 50
percent is required to ensure no furry
potentially cytotoxic monomer can be
released
so the specific wavelength we know is
within the specific region and the
spectrum changes over time I convert
this into a graph looking at the change
of spectrum over time
on the y-axis we have a degree of
conversion and on the x-axis we have
time in seconds from this we can see in
the first graph on the Left where's the
FTIR analysis was run for about an hour
and the decrease in initiate and active
it delays the monomer conversion by
approximately thirty minutes
hence the final conversion for an
formulation M two is not really
representative of the composite because
it's still reacting and then we can see
with M through there is no conversion
confirming that these levels are
obviously very low and far too low for D
formulation the second graph on the
right shows an increased range of
conversion options for the composite
where inhibition time is also varied now
the inhibition time is the pause before
the reaction sets off the assay shows we
can manipulate the inhibition and
conversion based on the desired outcome
which will inevitably depend on how much
time the surgeon needs to inject the
composite into the vertical fracture the
monomer conversion time desired by
surgeons also varies depending on their
experience
formulations allow for controlling the
level of conversion by changing the
levels of BP and MTG GMA where we can
see on the graph on the right by
increasing these components we can see
this obviously also reduce inhibition
time and we you need to solve way out
what's desired do you want a longer
inhibition time does the surgeon want a
shorter inhibition time or what what do
they prefer ideally higher the final
conversion the lower the risk of
leaching unconverted monomers which
poses less toxicity risks to patients
overall
furthermore during this reaction process
I mentioned the heater generated so
using a differential scanning
calorimeter the heat generated during
the polymer conversion was measured to
compare between our formulated composite
and the commercial PMMA so the
difference in heat generation was 0.3
degrees Celsius and according to
literature temperatures of surrounding
bone composite where they are exposed to
PMMA can exceed 70 degree Celsius now
the amount of heat generated and if you
want to calculate it is Irit the area
under the curve and large volumes of the
material will inevitably generate more
heat here only no point for seven grams
of material with use and normally in a
clinical setting approximately 10 grams
will use those a lot more
moving on to looking at the mechanical
and chemical mismatch so this is a table
and discover describing the tensile
strength and the modulus of cortical
bones and cancellous bone now a bone
consists of cortical cancellous bone
it's cut as a combination it's brittle
and it's ductile so it has the spongy
spongy part of the bone and has the hard
part of the bone which we'll familiar
with the tensile strength is the maximum
stress that a material can withstand
while being stretched or pulled before
breaking and the young's modulus is a
measure of the ability of a material to
withstand changes in length when under
length wise tension or compression is
applied and the best way to describe
this is if you imagine having a piece of
plastic ruler and you snap so you're
looking at how much strength it has
before the ruler snaps modulus is about
the materials elasticity so if you have
an elastic band if you pull the elastic
band and let's go you look at the
ability of elastic band to go back to
its original form I've also added the
commercial PMMA in comparison to the
tensile strength and modulus and you can
see it's very different and we want to
find something that is close to bone
so because this I say I am prepared ten
millimeter discs in diameter and 1
millimeter in thickness they were placed
in 10 milliliters of simulated body
fluid and we're left to incubate for 4
different time points using this essay I
looked at four different properties the
kind of cool properties we're look to
ultimate tensile strength and young's
modulus and to look at the chemical
properties i assessed remineralization
and component release
the ultimate tensile strength ultimate
tensile strength was assessed by
applying load to the disk at a certain
speed until the disks would fracture
you
this is a typical stress strain curve
and this shows on the graph what is
happening when load is author ephedra
stress is applied to the disk when the
disk fractures the fracture point is
registered
you
so here is a graph showing the change in
ultimate tensile strength over time in
the different formulations with varying
levels of monocalcium phosphate and poly
lysine if we look at the x-axis the
first two groups consist of 8% from the
calcium phosphate and the second group
consists of 4% mana constant rocket with
in the high and low levels of
monocalcium phosphate groups we also
have high and low levels of poly lysine
the first group has the highest amount
of monocalcium phosphate and poly lysine
and the last two groups have the lowest
amount of mana custom phosphate and
pretty nice and combined mean we can see
from the graph after one month the
tensile strength decreases in all the
groups and also increasing levels of
monocalcium phosphate and Polly lysine
decrease the tensile strength overall
getting the right proportion of
monocalcium phosphate and poly icing is
important we want to make sure the
material is tensile strength is optimum
to prevent fractures post-surgery
this graph is showing the Youngs modulus
the Youngs modulus as I mentioned before
is the measure of the ability of a
material to withstand changes in length
when under lengthwise tension or
compression ideally we don't want this
war to be two different two bones and we
can see the young's modulus can also be
influenced by increasing or decreasing
the levels of - housing phosphate and
poly licencing if we refer back to this
tables and add the ideal combined
formula we can see the lowest level of
NC PM and poly niacin gives us the
tensile strength at 9:19 better than
PMMA and modulus at two point three now
low modulus is also a good thing because
it tells us the material has more
elasticity if a material has a higher
elastic modulus it means that it's
difference is strong but permanent
deformation is likely alone
to listen to women it's more pliable
substance that exists versatile
mechanical characteristics such a
substance is actually good for the spine
due to the daily movement and
orientation
now to look at the kind
mismatched I did the same I faced
leaving my ten millimeter distant own
then litres of simulated fluid for four
different time points at 37 degrees to
explain a little bit about an
remineralisation the reactive calcium
phosphate in monocalcium phosphate
particles that they these are produced
upon neutralizing for Furyk asked with
calcium hydroxide calcium has calcium
phosphate I have precipitate from acidic
solution that's plate or needle-like die
calcium phosphate crystals and depicted
in the figure in the slide in
neutralizing body fluids however the
die-casting phosphate will transform
into balls of hydrophobic apatite
crystals with a porous honeycomb light
texture this is what we hope to see with
our material allowing bone integration
because the bone is also very porous the
hydrophobic apatite crystals have a
similar calcium phosphate ratio to bone
also thus the remineralization of the
composite will allow better integration
with burns as well as healing the
fracture type
here are the two groups with 8%
monocalcium phosphate and varying levels
of polarizing of a period of one month
images are taken using a scanning
electron microscope and the first image
at the top for each group is what the
disk surface looks like prior to being
placed in simulated body fluid the
images on the left for each group are
low magnification and images on the
right harmik magnification and here is
the same time period for the groups with
lower levels of monocalcium phosphate at
focusing and varying levels of poly
lysine again we can see both groups of
formation or some sort of lowering the
discs over time so we can see in all the
groups that over time we there is some
sort of layer that's being formed due to
the components within the disc and of
course what's in the simulated body
fluid and this is mimicking a clinical
setting of what may happen to this
composite when it's inside the body
ultimately the highest level of
monocalcium phosphate and polarizing
show the ideal physical appearance of
hydroxyapatite after one month and you
can see that there was this layer on the
dish and it's cracked and you can see
the ball like futures and all for some
noodle plate like features as well
finally looking at component release
this is important for a during
remineralization because we don't want
complete acidic conditions also
especially when I composites will be in
an environment where cells are to be
recruited for healing this is a graph
looking at the release of hydrogen ions
there's a square root of time and the
graph shows us that with increasing
levels of monocots and phosphate and
poly license combined the material
releases more hydrogen ions and the
lower when a calcium phosphate and lower
levels of poly lysine combinations this
needs to be studied further and assessed
because such conditions will influence
the cell environment for cell culture
studies also my next step is to assess
the poly lysine release independently
itself and to see how much is released
over time since we're trying to see if
this will play a big role in
antibacterial action
finals and the problem I'm trying to
address its toxicity
to do this I done I did some cell and
primary cell studies where I placed the
disks in the cell culture media at a
hundred rotations per minute for 24
hours at the same time i seeded cell
thirty thousand cells per centimeter
cubed for 24 hours in a 96-well plate
after 24 hours the leader from the cell
was removed and the media in which the
discs were submerged in that media was
added to the self
this is some left with 24 hours and
assessed by our Alamo blue
so on this graph here we can see the
metabolic activity of the cell and based
on what they were exposed to for the
first two groups are the high levels of
monocalcium phosphate with varying
levels of poly lysine 5 and 2 and then
the next two group with four percent
levels of monocalcium phosphate with
varying levels of poly lysine and then
the last two are the extracts from the
commercial PMMA and a control wealth and
we can see at 24 hours and 7 days how
the cells responded the extract was
collected after 24 hours and 7 days so
due to different types of extracts the
cells are exposed to and we can see that
the cells that were exposed to the
composites at higher levels of poly
lysines were lower than indeed
composites with lower levels of poly
licensing so we believe that too much
point icing isn't as good for cells and
I'd like to add also often poor license
actually use to plate and some materials
that are used for cell attachment often
to encourage their attachment at the
same time the study shows that maybe too
much green icing may not be great for
themselves but for analysis to be done
on this we also just was interested to
see the cell morphology what the cells
look like are they happy on the material
the image on the left is a
image for my scanning electron
microscope image taken where spells were
attached to the disk and also staining
with Dappy and Royden was done to see
the presence of cells just after 24
hours and the cells show there spreading
out and they're happy and they're flat
so this is a good sign that our material
creates conditions where cells will be
happy to today
finally I did an expose study and this
is where I used a camp si here you use a
chick egg you incubate it and at day
through your window do you create a
window j7 you add a graph and you in my
case the graft is my composite disc and
then you collect images and at day 14
you then collect the graph
instead of combined formulations I
wanted to see if individually the disks
releasing anything will pose any damage
or are toxic at all
so I had composite disks with no poly
life in the monocalcium phosphate the
lowest level of poly lysine at 2%
highest level of Khalil icing at 10% and
3% I want to monocalcium phosphate and
60% monocalcium phosphate
this is what the
chicken burgers look like prior to add
in the graph so you can see the window
in all the group of eggs I used and you
can see the vascular system of the chick
embryo it looks healthy it looks red
it looks fine the chick embryos are fine
too
over time I assess how the chicken
Brewers developed and finally at day 14
when I collected the graft the membrane
was attached to the disk so it shows the
disk created environment whether by the
membrane of the chicken Bree was happy
and I took some image images on a
scanning electron micrograph of these
and we can see red blood cells we can
see cells so this is a this is a pilot
study as well so we need to assess this
further and see what we're seeing why
we're seeing what we're seeing
for the highest level of monocalcium
phosphate at 16% we actually noticed on
the disk under the scanning electron
microscopes the physical characteristic
parents truly hydroxyapatite the ball
like structures suggesting that in this
environment the disks were able symmetry
mineralized not too different to what
may happen in the body
my service
my next step is to then as disks and
combined formulations as I've been doing
the other essays with where I've got
monocalcium phosphate and pull ice and
both together in the disk and as these
two become essays and see they do
whether they were mineral eyes or
whether they do black well for the chick
embryos as well
so in conclusion in terms of preparation
technique and hours is definitely easier
than the commercially available form in
the setting time we can influence they
can optimize and can be manipulated
easily hours material also generates
less heat than the commercially
available cement a lot of work still
needs to be done but our material is
closer to bone than the commercially
available cement and the material has
shown the ability to move mineralized
the in terms of toxicity these cells are
attaching and present and active of the
material showing that the material has
angiogenic properties because of its
success in the can't assay
the ideal material will then have as a
result if it osteogenic and angiogenic
it will be able to play the role of a
fused implant
future projects I'm interested on doing
further with these materials but looking
at cell migration cult culture with an
osteoblast and osteoclast and see how
they interact with the material and also
investigating if these formulations
encourage cell differentiation
I'd like to acknowledge my professor and
young and my secondary professor who is
good and bland previously and now my
secondary professor Tritiya Ferretti and
everyone else in the lab and hospitals
who have helped me who have provided me
with the cell samples and material and
the guidance that I've had
thank you so much
you
chinkyu mighta for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar now to our
audience if you have any questions you
would like to ask if you haven't done so
already please do so now just click on
that ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for okay let's get started we
have so many great questions already
coming in well okay my - let's start
with this one wouldn't you compare your
composite to the PMMA however what makes
your calcium phosphate composite
different to the already existing
calcium phosphate composite okay so like
I mentioned we there are several calcium
phosphate composites available in the
market already what makes our composite
different is that it's actually already
been tested in a clinical setting for
the teeth so we know it works very well
with the teeth and and the current
calcium phosphates that are available
there's limitations and we believe that
our composite has an advantage because
we're addressing these limitations and
hopefully our composite has an edge
because it has the antibacterial action
within it
hello
hi my Dionysus I let me repeat bed what
are the low in high magnifications used
in your graphs and photo Oh in the I
believe that question for the scanning
electron microscope so there was various
magnifications used the main
magnification I was going up to ten
thousand and lowest was about 250 Meg
thank you
in your Altman's party is your in vitro
experiment does it take into
consideration the micro environment in
the mouse a very good question actually
so my envy of experiment actually
doesn't do that these composites have
their experiments that have done for and
in clinical trials for the use of dental
composites those tests have been done
but my experiment doesn't but it would
be important to note that there is a lot
more bacteria and transfer infection in
the mouth and the oral cavity as opposed
to an environment within the bone so
there's less chances of secondary
infection using the composite in the
bone
very good thank you our next question in
your ex view x OV oh experiment what
were your visual observations besides
electronic microscopy findings and that
was a very good question and there
wasn't anything out of the ordinary in
looking at the expert experiment you
normally look to see how well the chick
embryo develops and if there's any
terminations if the embryo survived I
did look at the branching so when I took
the a camera imaging of my disks with
where you can see the blood vessels just
looking at how many branches this
indicates how well the material
encourages and just Genesis i'd like to
further look at other ways of assessing
how good it is but apart from that I
didn't do anything else for now
thank you the next question have you
tested whether this composite would
interfere with MRI or M RF scanning
signals for imaging purposes no I
haven't although it shouldn't but that's
a very good question and if you'd like
to reach out to me I could actually get
back to you because that's not something
I've looked at
thank you might up our next question I'm
curious that you have some data related
to particulate leeching over the period
of time and if so what would be the
consequences so it's looking at what the
Newton at the material can be good is
good and bad we want material to slowly
would be released from the material like
I mentioned we have manual monocalcium
phosphate and the release of this would
encourage remineralization of the disk
so that the physiology and structure
mimics bone so that it can allow bonding
of the bone we also want poly lisen to
be leached out and to be released slowly
for its antibacterial action however
obviously if too much is released out
leached out all of a sudden it will
change the pH it can make the
environment acidic and it can kill the
surrounding cells it can also we don't
know yet how but it can trigger an
immune response it could trigger an
inflammation so these things are
important to look at and we need to be
able to assess what parameters are good
and how much material should be released
but that means to be looked at further
- how did you characterize the
mineralized material a che by XRD or
FTIR sometimes salt also is absorbed on
the surface that's a very good question
that's in program progress at the moment
so that's not something I've done
okay thank you
what are the rationale for the
selections of 4% and 16%
M CPM
so the rationale was that we 50% would
be the Heian so that's the most amount
of monocalcium phosphate that's being
added we don't intend to add that much
in our composite and 4% being the lowest
so it just gave us a range especially
for the camera door just to see if
anything is a higher high range at that
level would be toxic to the chicken
brain or not and we saw that it wasn't
over time regular dental calcium
composite deteriorate and over time they
must be redone
how do you plan to prevent a
deterioration within the bone it's a
very good question and so the idea is
that because our composite remineralize
--is it may not require the composite to
be redone because that's actually a big
problem a lot of procedures a lot of
patients that undergo and vertebroplasty
it has to be done again because you get
adjacent fractures or there's an
infection or due to wear and tear the
compass is deteriorated so we would like
composite not to have that consequence
after it's used under patients and the
best way we aim to do that is to have a
composite that actually remineralize
--is and actually encourages new healthy
bone to be informed
- how different is the application of
the composite in healthy bone in
comparison to osteoporotic bone
so it's at essentially the same on
osteoporosis doesn't actually affect the
healing process so if you have a
fracture it will still heal and without
about six to twelve weeks of the ideas
that is composite will help
Mona what are the chances of the body's
immune response
responding to the composite so there's
actually a really good paper that talks
about how the immune response has
actually helped and with the with the
composites having one occur for however
that Newman the response actually helps
encourage stem cells to differentiate to
bone cells and most composites that are
used such as poly methyl methacrylate
they have compounds that leach and they
trigger an immune response which causes
is which can be problematic for the
patient but this is something that I am
very interested in looking at to see how
the immune response and how the immune
cells actually interact with the
composite component
Thank You Maya and we have pepper one
last question out of poly lysine in your
material work as an antibacterial so it
has a lot advantages and it is generally
recognized as a safe status because it's
used for a right to your food
application it's known to encourage
themselves to proliferate it can disturb
the bacterial membrane integrity
affecting their gene expression and and
so that's how it's known to sort of have
that antibacterial action it also
enhances our composites water sorption
and this promotes the release of anti
bacterial action agent from the
components that they sorry the composite
itself
Thank You mitre for this informative Q&A
do you have any final comments for our
audience either I just like to say thank
you so much to everyone who tuned in
today and I would like to acknowledge my
team once more at the Eastman Dental
Institute especially and my friends who
also scientists working with me
nazaneen-e Eileen and Celica I would
also like to give a huge thanks my
husband he is my greatest support and my
mom and my family who go above and
beyond especially helping me with my
kids and and I just like to say if you
would like to reach out to me you can go
to my biography path and then you can
visit and click my link there and
Instagram
thank you again mitre now before we go I
would like to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions there were few
questions we weren't able to answer
today so those questions we were not
able to answer live and those that are
continuing to be submitted during our
on-demand period they will be addressed
by Maite via the email address you
provided at the time of registration I
would like to once again thank my de
Arshad for her time today and her
important research we don't selected n
collaborates and our sponsor Thermo
Fisher Scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand and labret swil
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event you will
now be redirected to the registration
page of our next webinar titled
unveiling the role of t-cell dysfunction
in the development and progression of
glioblastoma by dr. Felipe Galvez
Cansino on June 18th at 9:00 a.m.
Pacific time 12:00 p.m. Eastern Time we
hope to see you there stay healthy and
we hope to see you again soon bye bye